la parole à Michel Savin pour le groupe
UMP
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur le ministre depuis votre
arrivée place Beauvau nous sommes
nombreux à adhérer à votre discours
particulièrement ferme et très
volontariste en matière de sécurité en
rappelant qu'il faut lutter contre les
phénomènes délinquants et mafieux
démanteler les trafics et combattre
l'exploitation de la misère qui s'y
greffe
mais ce qui paraît évident dans vos
discours mais malheureusement moins au
niveau de vos résultats comme un atteste
le dernier bilan de l'Observatoire
national de la délinquance et des
réponses pénales
alors je ne doute pas que vous aurez à
coeur de nous expliquer que les chiffres
manquent de fiabilité
restent que la plupart des indicateurs
sont à la hausse ces particulièrement
vrai en zone gendarmerie ou sur les 12
derniers mois les cambriolages ont
augmenté de 12% et les violences aux
personnes de 10,4%
dans ce contexte nos cent mille
gendarmes ont plus que jamais besoin des
moyens matériels indispensables pour
remplir efficacement leur mission or ils
éprouvent actuellement les plus grandes
difficultés à boucler leur budget 2013
lors de son audition devant la
commission de la Défense de l'Assemblée
nationale le 16 octobre dernier le
directeur général de la gendarmerie
nationale avait d'ailleurs attiré
l'attention sur les véritables
difficultés engendrées par un budget
sous tension
à titre de simple exemple le volume
d'essence disponible pour les 30000
véhicules de gendarmerie est en baisse
de 6 % par rapport à 2012 ces
restrictions portent également sur le
matériel informatique sur les véhicules
et les équipements nécessaires aux
militaires
autre sujet d'inquiétude
il serait aujourd'hui question pour la
direction de la gendarmerie nationale de
reporter le paiement des loyers dus aux
collectivités locales et ce pour
continuer d'assurer le bon
fonctionnement des unités
monsieur le ministre dans un contexte
économique et social difficile les
gendarmes sont notamment les premiers
exposés devant l'augmentation de la
délinquance il faut jour et nuit un
travail difficile et exigeant pour
garantir la sécurité de nos concitoyens
mais on ne peut pas leur demander plus
de résultats qui passent par une
présence accrue sur le terrain et dans
le même temps réduire leurs moyens
d'intervention aussi je vous remercie de
m'indiquer monsieur le ministre les
mesures que le Gouvernement en prend
rapidement pour garantir les crédits
nécessaires au bon fonctionnement de nos
gendarmerie
merci Monsieur Manuel Valls ministre de
l'Intérieur
monsieur le sénateur ça va merci de
l'attention que vous portez à la
situation de la gendarmerie
mais vous le savez
depuis six ans
les crédits de fonctionnement et
d'investissement de la gendarmerie ont
baissé sous la majorité que vous
défendiez
de 18%. moi je regarde la réalité en
face et je constate que depuis 30 ans
les violences sur les personnes ne cesse
d'augmenter
près de 30% au cours de six dernières
années et je constate que l'explosion
des cambriolages et là depuis 5 ans et
ces derniers mois et ces violences et
ses cambriolages sauf dans les zones de
sécurité prioritaire ont augmenté et
donc nous devons ensemble parce que ce
sont des sujets difficiles nous attaquer
assez phénomène et pour cela nous avons
décidé d'arrêter l'hémorragie que la
police et la gendarmerie ont connu en
matière d'effectif
6700 postes supprimés dans la
gendarmerie en 5 ans de remplacer tous
les départs à la retraite et de créer
tous les ans de 400 à 500 postes
supplémentaires de policiers et de
gendarmes donc la priorité à la sécurité
c'est à la fois des moyens et des hommes
et des femmes en plus c'est le choix du
gouvernement et c'est la priorité à la
sécurité souhaitée par le Président de
la République chaque année des
discussions ont lieu sur la fin de
gestion des budgets de l'État n'avons
pas échapper et le général Favier eu
raison de souligner les difficultés qui
se posent à la gendarmerie
pas seulement cette année mais au cours
de ces dernières années le Premier
ministre vient de décider de dégeler 111
millions de crédits de paiement pour la
police et la gendarmerie ainsi que 10
millions d'autorisations d'engagement
pour répondre aux besoins immobiliers
les plus pressants dans la gendarmerie
nationale pour le logement des familles
et j'ai eu l'occasion de l'annoncer ce
matin lors de l'examen du budget
sécurité en commission élargie à
l'Assemblée nationale et j'ai le plaisir
de le rappeler ici même dans votre
Enceinte cette décision du gouvernement
aura une conséquence très simple pour la
première fois mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs depuis 2007 les crédits
exécutés par la police nationale et la
gendarmerie nationale sont en
augmentation par rapport à l'année
précédente de 2% soit 40 millions c'est
à dire dans un moment difficile vous
laver rappeler pour nos finances
publiques nous augmentons des postes
dans la police et dans la gendarmerie et
nous donnons en fonctionnement et en
investissement des moyens
supplémentaires à la gendarmerie c'est
vrai pour les brigades de gendarmerie
c'est vrai pour les forces mobiles c'est
vrai pour le parc automobile de la
gendarmerie c'est vrai pour le carburant
c'est vrai pour les équipements
informatiques pour nous la priorité à la
sécurité ce ne sont pas des mots ce sont
des actes et nous les traduisons sur le
terrain